welcome to this video playing mah fault
my fault for not sure when this could
mean okay we got the fringe I am saying
hi big big honor ok ok so let's see
let's play some some more conventional
line for once I've experimented a bit
here with h6 moves like that ok maybe
try really a more close game I could
take on d5 of course still here black
has many possibilities if it should be 7
a-5 Queen B 6 maybe I can't start with
this I have an idea maybe try to play it
in a very very classical fashion there
should be seven castles and then taking
Knight b6 this is how I played it back
in the day when I've played the French a
bit more regularly the idea is to play
Bishop e7 and then a5 a4 fighting for
squares on them on on the on the
queenside blixem king stays on the aid
yeah I'd like to get an a4a 495 and if
everything is working out perfectly I
even get in Bishop b5 after some
preparation okay well this is this i
should really should play if I get the
chance I should play a form allowing
also to put a night on c4 if possible
93 and I play age five that's important
so that team and it's not getting in
night h5 himself all night a tribe is a
move after which you don't have a great
reply I don't want g6 I definitely don't
want to castle and I'm very often the
black king stays in the center here and
why not not getting mated in the middle
of the bottom sometimes even King f8 I
mean something like Knight a5 King f8
Queenie 8 we should be five comes into
consideration if I'm able to exchange
the light square Bishop the same will
probably be a very good position yeah
not totally clear to me what I should do
yeah
not purpose of this move is not totally
clear maybe default some sometimes later
no very often whites try something like
92 g 3h for Bishop g5 yeah switching
back to play on the dark squares and for
this age 3 does not help i spending
enormous amount of time I mean I could
at least I was able to play relatively
quickly as i am have had this type of
position a lot earlier I mean earlier
means years ago and pen so I'm invading
here take stakes I don't taking on c4
does not look very dangerous he does not
have a quick quick break through I think
that getting Bishop to c6 yes but I can
play Bishop c6 takes Bishop c6 this
looks good now my bishop is Sir you
transformed from questionable to to
really really good yeah probably
probably right hmm I don't want to take
on before that maybe I need to map it's
nots not that clear here everything
it's not clear
can I castle long here maybe even 10 and
to be five
hmm I can also take default by the way
this is this is also just good probably
yes night be three then will be a very
very problematic pin yeah I can just
take this and now night be three back he
can play going to be six but I can play
Queen B seven the pin is still in effect
I can also just just take the two I
guess he only has a check here Elijah of
course I yeah this is now a no deadly
the spin I'm not not sure where it
started to go downhill I mean normally
what white is doing is that after a five
he normally plays a move like be three
so that after a four you have before and
yeah then we go from here black might
try this maneuver exchanging the light
squared Bishop not so easy to get in wyd
sometimes not be 193 those kind of ideas
into a 4 and maybe here why should try
this as I mentioned this idea nighty to
g3 h4 and play on the dark square
especially to g5 yet it got it got
problematic who claimed he probably
shouldn't take on c4 this gives black
probably too much fun with this light
squared Bishop
especially here this looks very nice no
predefined fight yeah long castles is
something that we habit isn't this just
good maybe I should start with B 5 and
only later play this but it still looks
very good it's not clear though if he
just plays Queen III or something how I
continue this was of course very very
helpful like wins now something like
this and white white is Sir I mean a
black is a blessed Becca certainly a
fine here but how do you actually win
maybe I can play something like this
king he and later okay 8 a 3 e 2 to make
it to make a pass porn the sit bone now
but this is certified why does not
necessarily need to lose him okay thanks
for watching